Remember this place, of course, is
where I first asked you out.
I think it was me that asked you
right.
I guess it kind of
would have defeated the purpose.
But I'm saying it now.
Take charge.
Well, you can be a little intimidating.
You know, a girl can grow old
waiting for you to take charge.
We can all be as boulders.
I guess that's what I thought
you always wanted.
A stronger man.
Victor,
you know there is no mean Victor.
Never was.
that.
I wanted you to be that man.
Well, why didn't you say so?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, The Fantastic Four
and the X-Men are coming back
during Deadpool 3, so I can't believe
I never actually did a video
for The Wolverine Fantastic Four crossover
they tried to do years ago.
this was the beginning of them
crossing over the X-Men,
the Fantastic Four characters,
starting with the Wolverine character,
just because at the time he becomes
so popular.
So we'll break it all down.
Why they deleted the scene
and why Fox could never actually pull off
a Fantastic Four X-Men crossover,
even though there were multiple movies
where they tried to make them fight
like Captain America, Civil War, except
with the X-Men versus the Fantastic Four.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We'll get more footage of them all
coming back in Deadpool three pretty soon.
Hopefully they'll figure out
all the strike stuff pretty soon.
They want to see that drag into next year.
there'll be a lot of this crossover stuff
they'll set up in Loki season
two episodes, which I'll be doing videos
for when they premiere later this year
to I've already done a couple of videos
for some of the bigger cameos in Deadpool
three, like Chris Evans
coming back as his human Torch,
all the X-Men characters coming back.
I literally just did a video
about Channing Tatum
coming back as a version of Gambit,
all link all those videos
down the description below.
part of the reason so many
of the classic Fantastic Four and classic
X-Men are coming back,
and that is to pay off long running plans
that for several reasons, Fox
was never able to actually pull off,
namely Fantastic Four versus the X-Men,
The movies also adapting part of Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe,
except the joke is this Deadpool kills
the Fox Marvel Universe with them
clowning on the fact that Fox got bought
by Disney in the Fox Marvel movies
are kind of being relegated to legends.
Can kind of like
when Disney bought Star Wars.
That's why you're seeing the 20th Century
Fox logo be pruned on the Void planet
from the Loki series
Inside this Deadpool movie
like they got pruned
in sent to the void planet.
the story then trying to crossover
X-Men and Fantastic Four goes back
all the way to this very first Fantastic
Four movie in 2005.
That's where the deleted scene comes from.
In the deleted scene, Reed
Richards is talking to Sue Storm
about their relationship, the love
triangle they have with Doctor Doom.
that was a thing in the comics
like Doctor doom back to the classic
comics had been in love with Sue Storm
during different eras of the fantastic
Four stories
and they deleted the scene
before they polished the special effects
to digitally replace Mr.
Fantastic Face with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine face.
But you can clearly see
what they were trying to do.
It would have appeared as if Hugh
Jackman were in the actual movie itself,
kind of a more literal version
of the Deadpool Wolverine.
Funny scene at the end of the first movie
where he pretended that he was Hugh
Jackman just wearing the paper mask.
they do the same thing with the MCU movies
where there might be like a deleted scene
or like a cool idea
they had for an earlier movie
that winds up getting cut from the film
for whatever reason that they'll
bring back around in future films.
Ryan Reynolds
just taking the opportunity to clown on
some of those old deleted scenes
and ideas that never actually got paid off
when he did his Deadpool movies.
during the comics,
they ultimately wound up paying off
this whole idea
in the newer version of Secret Wars,
where Doctor Doom rewrites reality
with the power of the binders,
the multiverse was collapsing
because of the time runs out storyline,
and that'll be important in a second.
In the Marvel movies.
so to save all of reality, Doctor Doom
takes the power of the binders with Doctor
Strange his help and combines
all the fragments
of the remaining universes together
into a single world called Battle World.
But when he does that,
he also uses his power to rewrite reality
so that everybody living
there gets their memories altered.
So they think
things were always like this.
And as part of that
rewriting of everyone's memory,
Doctor Doom
makes Sue Storm fall in love with him
and they're a couple together,
at least for a little while till Reed
Richards comes back
now they're doing a version of Secret Wars
for Avengers six in the Marvel movies,
but it'll be slightly different
from the comics,
sort of a combination of the classic 1980s
secret wars in the more modern version
instead of God Emperor Doom
being the main villain,
it'll be another Kang variant with Beyond
or like Powers.
I believe right now
the rumor is it's
meant to be the original Kang
the Conqueror,
who everyone thought died
at the end of Ant-Man,
the WASP Quantumania
inside the quantum realm in a pay off
that time runs out storyline.
They're also supposed to be doing
a version of that for the Doctor Strange
three movie.
That's like a whole separate video.
I could talk for an hour
about what's going on during that,
so we'll do a video later this week
at some point,
you can see how they're trying to adapt
a lot of these different storylines
for what they're doing right now
in all the Marvel movies.
now in present day
Doctor Doom from those original Fantastic
Four movies is supposed to be coming back
in Deadpool three.
Julian McMahon is supposed to be in
the movie as a cameo for his doctor, Doom.
the movie is going to build on the events
of Doctor Strange, Multiverse of Madness,
Scarlet Witch Killed Reed Richards,
The Eighth Create Universe, The Junk
Brzezinski Version.
Since they're going back there
for the movie, they might pay off
some of that storyline with Doctor Doom
trying to put the moves on Sue Storm
now that Reed Richards is gone
because of what's happening
now, I also think that the doctor doom
they reference in the behind
the scenes commentary for doctor strange
multiverse Ibanez is the Julian McMahon
version of the character.
between detail of the teleportation device
he uses to get into the scene
is something we took from the comics.
That's Dr. Tune's Dr.
Doom's time door
all those 838 universe versions
are meant to be more comic book
accurate version.
So it's not the exact same version
from the Fantastic Four 2005 movie,
but it's one that's like that version
they'll be a totally new
MCU version of Doctor Doom
that they introduce in future movies.
I'll talk about that in my later videos.
the reason why Fox made them delete
the Wolverine cameo
scene from this original Fantastic
Four movie is because they just released
X2 X-Men United in their main X-Men
movies were more popular than ever.
Remember, this is the early 2000,
so they only just started doing
a bunch of comic book movies
Sony had just started doing the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies,
which were also hugely popular.
But at the time, the X-Men movies were
viewed as Fox's crown jewel.
They earned so much money for them
ultimately they decided they didn't
want this funny Wolverine crossover scene
to poorly affect the main X-Men movies
or any potential for a Wolverine
spinoff movie,
which they eventually did not long
after that with Wolverine origins.
They ended up having all kinds of problems
with Wolverine origins.
But at the time, years
before that, you have to remember
they're trying
to protect their brand like,
no, no, no,
this is a license to print money.
We can't mess with this.
Fox did restore
most of the deleted scene up to the point
they stopped working on it
in the original movie
for the extended version
of the DVD release.
So if you bought that extended version,
you might have seen this deleted scene.
Something similar wound up happening
in the original X-Men
movies with the Spider-Man crossover,
where it only appeared on
like a single version of the DVD release,
and then it kind of vanished in future
rereleases
The next time
Fox tried to crossover the X-Men
and the fantastic Four was in a full blown
Civil War type of movie
that would have basically been X-Men
versus the Fantastic Four.
For those of you
that wondered why they never wound up
crossing those characters over
in any of the original movies
and even the later first class
era X-Men movies, like Why wouldn't
you try to crossover the Fantastic Four?
back in 2013.
Simon Kinberg, who at the time was like
the main Marvel producer at FOX, announced
that they were developing
a crossover movie
with both teams going at each other
Civil War style, with Dr.
Doom being the main villain,
kind of like Baron Zemo was,
and Captain America, Civil War.
this was years before the Fantastic
Four 2015 reboot movie.
So this would have been the classic
Fantastic Four actors coming back,
even though at the time, like you remember
just turning the timeline out here
Chris Evans had been playing
Captain America in the MCU movies
for a few years in Marvel had just started
making the Winter Soldier movie.
So Chris Evans was already knee
deep in Captain America during the X-Men
First Fantastic Four movie.
This Dr.
Doom, the Julian McMahon version,
was going to orchestrate
a war between teams
to find the most powerful characters
and trick them into helping him
take over the world while also
killing any of the X-Men or Fantastic Four
who learned his secret
slightly flimsier plot than what they did
during Captain America Civil War.
like how do we get these two teams
to fight each other?
their movie would have started with Dr.
Doom causing Johnny Storm Human Torch
to cause a bunch of collateral damage
on accident,
killing a bunch of innocent people.
very similar to Captain America
Civil War with Scarlet Witch accidentally
killing a bunch of people,
and then people believing that Bucky
killed a bunch of people, but falsely.
some in the Fox version Human Torch would
have been kind of like the Bucky role
the one the X-Men and Fantastic Four
were fighting over what to do with him.
some of the characters
would have switched sides.
So it wasn't just the Fantastic
Four versus the X-Men.
It was like a mixture of both teams
going at each other
And even if it sounds like Fox would have
been copying Marvel in Captain America
Civil War,
remember that they were developing
this years before Captain America
Civil War.
So technically, had this got made,
it would have been Marvel copying Fox,
they had the writers from X-Men
First Class developed the script.
They were the same people that Marvel had.
Right. The first Thor movie.
So already lots of crossover energy
between Fox and Marvel happening here.
you might have seen the writers talking
about this deleted movie like they wrote
most of the movie
before they ultimately canceled plans.
the reason why it never actually got made,
even though it could have turned
into a solo crossover movie
was because of X-Men Days of Future Past.
The writers of the Fantastic
Four X-Men crossover movies said that
behind the scenes, Fox executives learned
that Bryan Singer had signed on to
come back and direct another X-Men movie
he'd agreed to do Days of Future Past.
Basically, They knew they'd be able
to get all the classic X-Men actors
back in the new first class X-Men actors
and cross them over.
in Fox saw the regular mainline solo
X-Men movies as being way more valuable
to them, like a license to print money.
So they went with the days of future
past idea and scrapped the Fantastic
Four crossover idea,
also didn't help that the previous
Fantastic Four solo movies
kind of bombed theatrically.
that's when they decided
to reboot the Fantastic Four movie
with the 2015 version because they weren't
doing the crossover movie.
Ultimately it wound up being even worse
for the Fantastic Four franchise. But.
It went great for the X-Men.
Days of Future Past
is still a pretty solid
X-Men movie now, like the Rogue
Cut is a little bit better version
of that movie than the theatrical version,
but still overall, a pretty solid film.
They also ultimately wound up
kind of losing their franchise
mojo with the X-Men during Apocalypse
and then Dark Phenix.
So ultimately their Fantastic
Four franchise and their X-Men franchise
both kind of fizzled out
no matter what that crossover movie
might have saved the Fantastic
Four franchise for them,
but we also would not have gotten Days
of Future past.
So you can let me know in the comments
if you would have
rather seen the crossover movie,
if it would mean no Days of Future
past Disney eventually bought Fox
and the point was moot.
Now Deadpool three is essentially going
to pay off all those deleted scenes,
all those canceled plans, running ideas
for crossover movies that never got made,
sort of like a swan song for the Fox
Marvel characters, tying off
as many loose ends before Secret Wars.
This is probably just the beginning.
I'm sure we'll learn about all kinds of
canceled plans and deleted scenes, things
that they never revealed up until Deadpool
three starts to pay those things off.
So of course, they'll do more videos
as we get more footage from that film
Next week, my associate episodes
are going to start right after that
Loki season two episodes
that will connect with Deadpool three.
So be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here for my Deadpool
three Gambit video and click here
for my brand new Loki Season
two trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching everyone
Stay safe and maximum effort!